vicki do you want to be here i i i think
i think eight days is a long time well
then why'd you sign up for it
because i did no but then
it's too much for you why'd you sign up
okay someone's gotta support me listen
to say
like the countdown or this many days
like i'm excited to see my grandsons on
saturday i'm super excited about that
friday night actually yeah but we're in
the we're gonna be in the moment no no
no i'm good i'm i'm not typically used
to eight days with a bunch of women i'm
usually saying you've been here vicky
you just seem a little bit like
depressed i'm doing my best i'm not in a
happy place and stop being the victim
not being vegan you're you're you're a
victim no you are a victim
this is not you i am a positive [ __ ]
and the first thing you say when you
come to my house is i'm in a bad place i
need to stop steve i was like i know but
we don't want to hear it then it's the
next day another thing then the next day
it's urgent care you went to urgent care
to get a steroid shot you didn't have a
gunshot wound okay yeah
honestly after the steroid shot it has
been good yes let's give her some
steroids who has steroids you took your
nap now tonight you need to do this i've
never slept before in the middle of a
day yeah i was i just hit the wall i
couldn't function well i just feel like
you're a little bit like slow to
the upside yeah
we need to be present we need to know
you don't talk to me that way okay
she's right the way dorinda describes
her frustration is a little bit more
understandable considering she's hosting
all of us ladies in her home and so to
see someone not wanting or giving an
effort it gets a little frustrating no
no go home complaints because we just
want you to
turn it up
in defense of vicky is she whooping it
up no but she is
a little bit just a little woo-woo not a
wolf but a little woo woo
i think there's progression here i want
to hear about what happened between you
and joe
we were all told she works in the
morning you knew she didn't she told you
several times i was told leave her alone
she's doing a job kind of protect her
and you kept on it and on it so i did
say kept on it and on it after a
beautiful night down to this the woman i
brought from queens to strip for us
like down to everything the most
beautiful night however this is about
something bigger so that's what i said
when you came with lou
to fill with me i was i was told by my
producer you have to do this thing with
ramona i'm working jill you remember
working right eight years ago you
remember working right don't try to put
me in my workers the the producers had
to go ahead finish with ramona
i think that you were drinking a lot
that night as you fought with ramona do
you think it's nice when you have a good
girlfriend i just got here and when they
don't like something they say right away
are you drunk wow i miss you girls you
know what the strange thing is there was
no tequila i saw you with my own eyes
why are you drinking all that now watch
the episode yeah you okay here we go
episode say some alligator that does not
taste like chicken not the chicken that
i buy no
i'm gonna get those organic chickens
and don't take a singer at me i was on a
show that you're no longer on
don't call me thirsty honey okay
i haven't been with dorinda a lot in the
last couple of years my only experience
honestly is watching her on television
and she just self-destructs when she
drinks i don't know why she does it but
of course i don't know why people drink
because i don't drink i have a i have a
question no don't don't say don't let us
say you know what don't you ruin the
whole night for all of us yeah you did
because it was beautiful we should have
turned it up and had fun we had a great
day you were just no hold on you were
hysterical over what
what were you hysterical over that was
histrionics oh my god i don't have to
defend myself and for you to try to make
me feel bad about feeling bad instead of
being historically
okay i have to say something all right
so you came into phaedra's room and
dropped a bomb about bobby's funeral and
left what's the barbie funeral robbie's
funeral it's her name
i said she said i was there the day
after and you were talking about gary is
that not true
whether it's true or not i don't think
it was a nice thing but you were you
said should i start he's a friend of
mine and i know it's difficult live by
your truth but you guys both said some
[ __ ]
i didn't talk to you on the day of your
federal we were filming because you made
us film that day bobby loved you i know
i know i know i know i'm alone now i
don't want to do that we're all alone
i'm going to do that what am i going to
do i didn't know there wasn't anything
cameras were there
yeah no no no no no no you can't do that
you called them you have to get rid you
have to get ready
oh no are cameras there if jill didn't
authorize it so what is the truth i've
never known there to be a camera at a
funeral i kind of want to know a little
bit more
but i kind of don't want to know a
little bit more the cameras are there
you talked to bethany about it brought
cameras i didn't know she was miked
and that's the truth they called me and
said jill wants me to film
[Music]
you